the layer heil pen show sponsored by step
finance your go to d5 portfolio manager
on solana luna if you're just getting into
bitcoin it's the perfect place to start
hey guys anna welcome back to the lay higher
plans show as always it is powered by the vc
firm icon plus capital and it is sponsored by
block five so if you want to check them out
i've left a link somewhere in the description
in the bio i'm not really sure in the comments
so go check them out so joining me today i
have a really exciting guest somebody who
we should have done this in person which we
were just saying before the show um but we
will do eventually but today it's gonna be
really interesting um i think we differ on
a lot of different issues so i'm really excited
to delve into this and i'm actually under strict
instructions to make this juicy so joining
me today is the founder of what bitcoin did
journalist filmmaker and chairman of real
bedford fc it is peter mccormack what's up peter
hi elaiah how are you are you doing well i'm
good hiding i'm good i'm just retweeting out
let's get some people in here um yeah but look
juice like just let's get into some interesting
topics because yeah there's a lot to talk
about and yeah these podcasts where you just go
where discover bitcoin yeah all those kind of
things they're done over and over let's just go
like if we've got limited let's get let's just get
in some interesting topics and let's keep it very
english and very civilized okay let's do it as i
said um we do differ on lots of different issues
but i'm sure once we delve into them we'll find
common ground but i know you didn't want to do
the basic stuff but i do just want to start and
talk about um real bedford fc because that is so
cool so you're the chairman of bedford football
club just explain that to me and where does
bitcoin come into this yet yes and no there's
a complicated answer to that so we are still
going through the process of the acquisition uh
we've established the company nakamoto 11 limited
the team we established next season will be called
rail bedford the team we are acquiring is bedford
fc but there are some complexities involved in
the purchase but we are being supported by bedford
football association and getting that over the
line so there's just some things we're dealing
with there we can't talk about it all because
there's just the things that have to be done
um and so some people are like moaning at us on
twitter etc but yeah once once the uh acquisition
is complete we'll explain like everything that
happened and why it took a bit of time but yeah
it's very exciting um yeah it's the most exciting
thing in my life right now i get to go and watch
this team every week and uh influence their future
so yeah it's very exciting i'm loving it yeah so
what does it mean though to have bitcoin a part of
it where's the bitcoin connection how's that come
into it i know you have the gemini sponsor which
was amazing yeah i mean to me it was all about uh
i'm from bedford and and you know anyone listens
to my podcast or following me on twitter i'm very
proud of this [ __ ] little town i'm from um i
grew up here my friends are here i still live here
um and it's very easy to move away from
your [ __ ] little town go to a big city
london new york and live that life and contribute
to that economy but i've always wanted to support
the local economy of bedford um because it's where
i'm from and i want to help it it is a it is a
deprived town um a lot of the big companies that
used to be here years ago aren't here anymore um
there are families here who struggle
um and i always felt like i've been
so up late i've been so lucky this last few
years and what's happened with the podcast
um that i i was like what can i do for my town and
i always felt like it was a town that's big enough
to support a football league club uh we don't
we've never been in the football league bedford
has never had that and i've always felt
like it's a town that can support it
so as a plan how can you make this happen and uh
it just hit me like six months ago i was like well
hold on a second if i just make them the bitcoin
team i know what bitcoin is alike bitcoiners
love microstrategy even though they don't really
know what what they do or care about it and they
love michael saylor and then that they they now
absolutely love el salvador is everyone's favorite
country i was like well if i do a bitcoin based
company and uh maybe this is something they'll get
behind the support and if if i can make that
work then i can make the economics work and
and so far it's been fairly successful i've sold
i think close to a million pounds of sponsorships
um our merch sales in our live we've done nearly
fifty thousand pound in merch styles with merch
sales which for a club in the tenth tier is like
it's ridiculous i mean we're we're heading for a
year one revenue of a low league two club and so
that just puts us in this position where we can
afford to invest in the team the players and local
football and you know if i can make this work if
i can bring league football to bedford that's
going to create jobs in bedford that's going
to bring just like just like something cool for
the town and then away teams coming here they're
going to bring fans who are going to spend money
in the town so like this is this is like this cool
thing where i get to i get to do three things at
once i get to like live out a personal dream and
go on which is just a yes every bloke's kind
of one of maybe some women too but like every
bloke's kind of dream is to own their their
local football club um i get to do that i get to
uh support my local town which i love and i
also get to promote bitcoin i just bring all
like allowing these things to converge at once so
so yes it's amazing i feel very blessed and lucky
that people are supporting this that's amazing
when i saw you doing it i was so um i was like
so happy because i love to see people staying true
to who they are and um you know with the success
kind of giving back um no so i i love it like i'm
following your journey and i'm a fan i think it's
great um so yeah let's go into this okay so
when we were talking about you know what we
should what we should talk about you said to me
um you know people call you and i quote a statist
cuck i don't know what that means okay i don't
know what that means i know what status is i
don't know a carcass honestly you definitely know
what a cuck is coming you just don't want to make
a man whose wife is sexually unfaithful that's uh
that's what they refer to so uh i think it's just
it's used as like a uh it's a derogatory term to
imply that you're a bit of a [ __ ] or something
um right and because i'm somebody who's like
there's in the bitcoin community there's a lot
of libertarians and uh people who think democracy
is completely failed they want a downfall of the
state and i am somebody who believes in democracy
and and we can get into that it's not just like
some irrational opinion i've come to i am somebody
who believes in democracy and rather than burn it
down i'd like to strengthen it i recognize its uh
failings but i spend a lot of time researching it
i i don't just look at uh democracy i look at
other forms of governance and it's an error i'm
really interested in but but often i get called
a status cuck online which which has it's it's a
it's a strange term to throw at someone because
it's kind of coercive because who wants to be
called a [ __ ] and i want to be called a car
can i also be called a [ __ ] so it's kind of
a coercive term it's like well if you're if you're
a believer in democracy and if you uh then you're
a [ __ ] and therefore you're a percy and you're
not one of us and therefore like who's gonna admit
that so what it does it actually stifles debate
about what is a really super important subject
is governance like how do we govern ourselves uh
everyone is looking at canada right now and seeing
how authoritarian they are becoming but that's
only within our cohort um they their parliamentary
vote went through overwhelmingly um to extend
the uh special powers and also if you if you
kind of slip out of you this kind of bitcoin or
crypto cohort and you go into some of the other
fees or other discussions regarding this there's
lots of people who very much against the truckers
uh and who very much support the government what
they're doing so um for me um yeah being called to
stay this cocky it's kind of annoying um but
at the same time i'm not going to be coerced
into changing my beliefs i'm i am someone who
believes in democracy and it comes from uh
a number of different angles and it also comes
with this thing where people are like oh if you
believe in the government uh then you're not a
bitcoiner like or you don't understand bitcoin
and i always think again that's kind of like
a statement um of that comes from kind of a
naive and immature place because uh bitcoin has
no political political idea like ideology is
it's money and yes it's money outside of the
control of the state but it doesn't it doesn't
define it as a as a way to bring down the state
it is not implied that by using bitcoin you're
you're trying to bring down the
state for me bitcoin is actually
something that i think can make democracy
stronger by becoming a a check against power
a check against the state by uh hopefully leading
to more uh responsible economic policy and if you
look to somebody like josh mandela who's in ohio
at the moment and you can watch his debate between
himself and morgan harper and he's a bitcoinman
but he what he talks about is smaller government
bigger people and if you want for smaller and
bigger people you support bitcoin if you want for
big government small people then you don't support
bitcoin so i'm kind of in that space and i'm not
just going to be sucked in and say um oh i'm a
libertarian let's burn it all down or um let's um
get rid of the state um just because other people
are saying it because i just don't believe it
so i think it's an important subject and it's
something that's kind of like worth diving into
yeah let's go into it because um this
is something that i always kind of found
that i didn't understand with you and i
think a lot of people might feel similar
who identify themselves as bitcoins or whatever
so to choose bitcoin right and to sort of put
it on this pedestal is this idea that you in my
opinion are suspicious of authority that's why
we want to decentralize the power decentralize
the network you're suspicious of central banks
because they print more money do you agree i'm not
suspicious that the suspicion is like oh i think
something might be happening i'm not suspicious
at all i think i think government and central uh
central banks have been hugely irresponsible with
economic policy for this but for decades now i
mean they used to run surpluses and and deficits
now there's there's no such thing as a surplus
everything is a deficit and a growing deficit
you know we've moved from this place of kind of
financial responsibility i'm not suspicious i
i absolutely detest what they've done but just
because i don't like what's happened with central
banks and government doesn't mean i want to burn
it all down it's just we've evolved to this place
and i think it's like how do you strengthen it now
yeah i agree i also don't want to burn it down
i would i would call myself a libertarian but
i don't think we should burn it down and i'm for
democracy not an anarchist at all but i just feel
that how do you swear that how do you square
yourself as a libertarian but for democracy
so i think that there's a spectrum like i
don't think everything is black and white
and so i generally speaking i'm a libertarian that
believes in small government and i'm suspicious of
government so when the lockdown started i was very
very suspicious mainly because you know i saw what
happened in the 20th century and i understand that
if you give a little bit they will take a mile
and so this is another topic i wanted to get into
with you you were pro lockdown and i understand
that for a very short short amount of time what
happened what changed well i just saw the evidence
that didn't work i mean at the very start the
reason i was pro lockdown is because firstly
we had these kind of weird videos coming out of
china people collapsing on the floor and dying
but i was following the news reports in italy
italy was the first country in europe that was you
know severely affected by covid um and uh i was
following the journalists reports going into these
uh villages and towns that were showing that
people like a lot of people the hospitals were
overrun and people were dying and because italy
was the first that was badly hit so it looked
scary i then did an interview for my other i
used to have the other podcast defiance and i
did an interview with my friend who's a doctor
in london that interview is still available
and he he i mean he cried in the interview he
was under so much stress because what happened
was they had a trickle and then they had then very
quickly within a couple of days the hospital was
overrun by people and then they had to declare
an emergency because they couldn't deal with
everyone coming into the hospital so they're
having to ship people into other hospitals so
i think there was a natural reaction to that
to say well holy [ __ ] this we don't know how
bad this is going to be and i fully supported
the idea of of a lockdown as as a as a method
of kind of like easing off on the pressure on
what was happening but what happened was over
time it became evident that that that lockdowns
actually had a massively detrimental effect and
i very quickly changed my mind and yeah thinking
that a lockdown is a good idea doesn't make you
an evil person you know it came from a rational
place and when i was wrong i i admitted i was
wrong i was like i got this wrong but i can't say
it i would change my view in the same situation
because in the same situation i'd be dealing
with the same information i think at the time
it it was logical for many people to think okay
a lockdown seems like a good idea but we were
told it was a two-week lockdown but why did you
believe them why did you believe them that's what
i'm saying with this like suspicious mentality
why did you believe it would just be two weeks
i'm just going with the information that's
put in front of me that i'm uh speaking to
a doctor who's telling me the hospital's overrun
and seeing the uh the government investing
building these nightingale hospitals so they
could deal with overflow and they said there was a
two-week lockdown and i was like yeah that sounds
like a sensible idea very quickly after kind of
like month two months three months it's obvious
this isn't a good idea we saw the impact on uh
family life on businesses and you know i very
quickly changed my mind but this is one of the
problems with something like twitter if things are
taken out of context or you you say one especially
if you've got hundreds of thousands of followers
you say one wrong thing these little minions want
to just hold it against you for the rest of your
life like they've never said something stupid in
their life or they've never made a mistake and and
also like like i said this this doesn't come from
a place of like evil this comes from a place of
rationality just trying to i'm somebody here with
two children as well who are uh are scared because
they they don't understand what's happening so
yeah it just came from a rational place i changed
my mind quickly and i admitted i was wrong on it
yeah and i appreciate that i think that like i
wish more people would you know be um confident
and confident with themselves enough to
be presented with new information and say
actually you know i feel a bit differently on the
topic but there's a sorry there's an inertia to
admitting you're wrong so what a lot of people do
if they've got something wrong they will double
down i've historically found that actually if
you if you get make a mistake and you admit
you're wrong and say you're sorry you have this
like small percentage of people who who will like
be like oh you're a flip-flopper but generally
speaking what happens you build a trust in your
audience because your audience goes oh well look
he makes mistakes and he admits when he's wrong
okay great i can trust him i can trust what's
coming out of his mouth is probably the truth
and you just have to accept like there's this
small little angry crowd of people who who don't
like you for that yeah no i agree with you and
i think um i've been following you for a while
and i think that what i've noticed that you've
changed your stance on a lot of different things
since being in crypto bitcoin and since you know
building more of a community and more friendships
in the bitcoin community and one that i noticed
was guns am i right you change your stance on guns
i have a complex id i have a complex view on
guns so uh i was very like yeah i mean i was
very anti-gun four or five years ago because
um we don't have guns here really i mean
some some people own guns but i'd only
shot a shotgun once clay pigeon shooting
quite happy to live in a society without
guns and i i don't really want it i
you know i'm a bit older than you so i remember
the hungerford killings where michael ryan
uh ran around hungerford and killed some like 13
people uh you might not even uh you probably don't
because you're quite young you probably don't even
remember um dunblane because i was about 15 when
that happened and that was up in scotland where
uh i can't remember his name but this weirdo went
into a school and shot a bunch of bunch of kids
i just don't like guns and i don't like gun crime
um and then also just seeing the massive shootings
over the years in the us i'm i'm just not a fan
of guns so i was very much anti-guns and and now
i've got to kind of again try and take a nuanced
position as best possible um when i go to the us
uh i love to go shooting i've been shooting with
jameson larp i've been shooting recently with
a few beam texas i enjoyed it and i've learned
a lot about gun safety and and such um and i
mean firstly i wouldn't be arrogant enough to
say that um i think my opinion matters or what
the rights for people i'd have guns in the u.s
and i have definite empathies with both sides of
the argument because i've interviewed people who
are proponents of guns people like ragnar
uh i also interviewed a lady works for a
charity called texas consent sense who her son
unfortunately killed himself with a gun so i've
seen the range of uh arguments for it but what
i would say is like whilst i appreciate and
understand guns in in the us i have no desire to
change the rules in the uk and i wouldn't even do
it just to virtue signal to bitcoin as you listen
to my show i think bringing guns into the uk would
be an absolute disaster i don't i mean look if you
really want in the gun in the uk you can get a gun
by the way you can get a shotgun you can get a gun
you just there's just very strict restrictions on
how the cabinet they're held in how it's locked
and they come and do checks but do i want liberal
gun policies in the uk like they have in
texas that anyone can go buy a gun no i mean
and i don't think it's you know we have a
social contract here in the uk and and we
have a democracy and if it was put out to vote i
i think you would have a very tiny vote i mean i
i imagine less than five percent of people would
want it so this kind of like and this goes to this
idea of trying to export cultures around the world
or just because you know just because people in
america have their first and second amendment they
think the rest of the world should have it but
trying to export the cult uh export the culture
of america across the world has have met many
negative externalities i think i've just come to
the point of trying to appreciate that different
countries have different cultures i enjoy
guns in the u.s i don't really want them here
that is a very um nuanced and gray-ariad
response i agree that it would be irresponsible
to adopt the gun culture in america in
the u.s in the uk it just wouldn't work
um but in terms of if you look at canada
though do you think we should do you think
we should have guns here i don't think it
would work and i think it would be dangerous
because i just think that i support guns like
i i support guns i think i think guns are very
important i'm suspicious of the government um
the last two years has shown me um you know
we need to protect ourselves and particularly
with what's going on in canada um but i think it
would be like the pros would outweigh the cons in
some way i think if we had you know guns suddenly
imported into the uk it would be disastrous so you
mean the you mean the cons would outweigh the pro
the the cons with outweigh the pro thank you yeah
thanks that could be taking out contacts and i
i just don't think i know that you in america in
1776 because they had guns they were able to take
on our tyrannical british government and throw a
tea into the sea and yada yada um i just don't see
a scenario in the uk whereby like we have that
uprising which requires us to have guns to take
on the target government and yes it could happen
but it's i think i'm thinking about probabilities
i think the probability of a scenario where we
as a nation needs to rise up i just think it's
unlikely and and i think the net effect on guns
in the uk would be negative we already have a
knife issue and uh i don't think throwing guns
into that mix is uh particularly useful i was
uh i was having um i was having uh lunch with an
old school friend the other day in the gym and uh
he works for the police he works from
the net and he works on organized crime
he said there's such an issue with getting
guns in this country it's so hard to get a gun
guns are reused so what happens is a gun will
be used in multiple crimes so one person will
have it and then it goes to another and they
loan it they loan it out around the country
to be able to do these crimes there was a scarcity
of guns so if there were more guns there wouldn't
be that scarcity and then there would likely
be more crime associated with it and yes look
i don't have a gun to defend myself in my house
but the uk is relatively safe and when people
bring up the knife crime it's it really is that's
mainly gang on gang crime that is a a an issue of
deprived estates where there's no opportunity
a lack of parenting a lack of father figure and
people are joining gangs and and part of being
in the gangs haven't having a knife so i just
don't i just don't see any positive uh outcome
for the uk having a a gun culture like the us
my only issue with that is i know you said we're
relatively safe here but we could have been canada
like we could have been canada and i think what
concerns me with canada it's not it's not similar
to america because the restrictions are different
you just you can't even leave your country
you're literally a prisoner to your country
unless you've not had a certain medicine i want
to like keep um buzzwords off this um you know
you're you're literally a prisoner in your own
country you can't even get a domestic flight if
you haven't had medicine but it's not a medicine
it is what it is but i don't want to say
certain words because youtube will just
i don't know demonetize shadow and stuff
like that but you know what i'm referring to
yeah of course but they have guns in canada so why
why aren't the truckers bringing out their guns
i mean it's not a scenario rules uh i don't think
so exactly i don't think it's the exact same rules
but but you can have guns in canada but what what
do you think would happen like if they had i mean
look at new york you've got uh you've got quite
you've got mandates within new york i was meant
to be there this week i couldn't go because
my daughter's not vaccinated so that that can
happen i mean look what what do people suddenly
think in these scenarios everyone's going to
suddenly bring out their guns and you've got to
remember that whilst trudeau in our cohort is not
particularly popular there are other people who
do support him so what they're going to descend
into civil i don't think this is a scenario where
they descend into civil war and i don't think this
is so i think we're we're far from that uh and
you know well i mean like i'm a massive critic
critic of uh uh justin trudeau i think he's a [
__ ] [ __ ] but at the same time like they're a
democracy and he's democratically elected and uh
and my my biggest criticism is they're trying to
uh clamp down on dissent and use tools such as uh
uh uh like blocking your finances to stop descend
i think that's bad but that may be something
they go through the democratic process and
and a conservative party comes in and repeals that
i don't know how it works out but at the moment
i'm i'm not seeing a scenario where i'm like oh
we suddenly need a us-based gun policies in the uk
yeah and i understand that i think um the last two
years has just pushed me and a lot of other people
and i think even you to some extent more towards
a certain you know smaller government ideology
um and i would never i would never say it would
never come to the uk because i think we were so
close to being um to being canada but in
terms of you know without knife but really
no i take issue with that how do you
think we were so close to becoming canada
because there was there was a moment we
had vaccine passports for starters right
we had those all be it was for three weeks i
truly believe if yeah we did for three weeks
we had vaccine passports and major for like for
like um for like clubs for major things like um
clubs big big events concerts that was
the idea that's what was implemented
yeah for a very short period of time for three
weeks during a pandemic when you know people are
getting sick and dying that it was a tool
of the government to try and open up the
economy by what but at the same time but but
at the same time inventory and it's not okay
well no look look i think i think you can look
into the nuance of this look i don't support
mandates and passports but i understand what
the government was in a tricky position because
uh they're trying to the role of the government
is to support the electorate and the electorate
is what votes and puts the government in power
and the electorate is a wide range of views from
those who are uh uh who believe in like ultimate
freedom and and those who want safety from the
government and they're in a very tricky position
and the nhs was completely overrun at one point
now there were people dying they're vulnerable
people dying people with co-morbidities
and i think whilst i disagree with the lockdown
the government's in a very tricky position in that
they're trying to open up the economy but trying
to protect the national health service at the same
time so i think what it was naturally doing was
trying different tactics and one of the tactics
is saying look if you're going to go to wembley
stadium uh and going to go and watch england
ideally you don't have covert because it's a
it's a it's a event with a lot of people and
it could lead to a big spread and that spread
could lead to a lot of people going to hospital
and a lot of sickness and illness so i don't
support passports we understand why they did
it but i think it's a massive stretch to say that
we're close to becoming canada we could have been
because they think the reason why all of this
has been reversed is for several reasons first
reason is because boris johnson broke our lockdown
rules right or his own lockdown rules how can you
implement further things if you didn't even take
the damn thing seriously in the first place if
your leaders aren't afraid of the virus like why
should anyone else be so that's the first thing
how can you get how can you continue second thing
is i think that we had a lot of um people speaking
out against it online um and i and you know really
holding the government to account because we had
those kind of leaders um and i think they we i
for me personally like i think we owe them a huge
like thank you for you know every single day
fighting speaking um and standing up for it if we
didn't have that i think we would have continued
i mean we didn't even have any opposition from the
labour party i mean kierstarma was totally in
favor of more restrictions back in december
but this is how democracy works democracy works
in that you have the push and pulling within
government and you have the push and pull of the
people and you have the you have the right to
demonstrate you have the right to protest now we
had the right to protest in the uk and there were
protests and people were heard we were i would say
during this entire process we've been a very well
functioning democracy which is that sometimes
done things that like people disagree with but
i think this is why sometimes it's important
to step out of your cohort because within your
cohort it's very easy to think like everything is
uh authoritarian everyone is becoming a nazi but
if you actually step out of that cohort and go and
look into different groups like a large percentage
of the population very much supported what the
government did this is why i spent so much time
talking to doctors and nurses visiting hospitals
and speaking to people on the front lines because
they were the people who say to you look we're
in a difficult situation here at times yeah these
hospitals were overrun they were dealing with lots
of people dying now that doesn't mean lay i don't
criticize the government and the complete [ __
] hypocrites i do i absolutely [ __ ] criticize
them but at the same time i i don't i think it's a
long stretch to say we're close to becoming canada
i actually think as a democracy we function really
well you know if you actually look in europe
we probably outside of like sweden and belarus
we're like one of the first countries to
completely open back up and start pulling back
the restrictions which surprises me it surprises
me but that's where i'd like that's where i
challenged you we were close to becoming canada
i think we're a long way from becoming canada
i think we actually functioned as a democracy
in this process now listen not again again refer
back to our cohort a lot of people in it will not
agree with it because they just hate any form of
government so any kind of like any kind of like
rope i give them any kind of like leeway i give
them like well [ __ ] you government's terrible
but i am somebody who supports democracy and i
think we function as a democracy fairly well we
saw the flaws in government and what we're seeing
is you know people were removed from government
uh hancock the absolute [ __ ] [ __ ] uh was a
complete hypocrite and he's you know he lost his
uh place in the cabinet uh boris johnson's
massively under threat almost certainly the
conservatives will not be voted in in the next
election because because of their handling this
and their parties and that's how democracy works
my my biggest problem with democracy is is that
we have this great pull between the left and the
right and especially in the uk being a not being a
two-party system we have that kind of like ability
that if you're if you're if you're pissed off with
a conservative pistol for labor well there's
other parties you can vote for you can influence
they don't have that in the u.s but my biggest
problem is whether you have this poll left or
right because you know yeah they had that pendulum
swinging from you know from more conservative
policies to more liberal policies government still
gets bigger and this is where i wish libertarians
would engage in politics more because yeah i
fundamentally agree with libertarians i just
think a lot of the ideas just don't work out in
reality but if libertarians if there were like
libertarian parties with a larger uh uh control of
the vote especially in a representative democracy
as well as having that left and right you
would hopefully have that pull between
big and small government we don't have that
thing that is trying to create smaller government
because government always gets bigger it's what
eric voorhees told me years ago he said i just
wish government would get smaller i think if we
had more libertarians in government and more like
a stronger libertarian party not only we would
have that push left and right which balances the
needs of different people in society we would also
have that push and pull on the size of government
that's a really good point actually didn't
occur to me um because we often think you
know by voting conservative you're voting
for a smaller government but you're not
can i um i just want to respond to somebody
i'm just seeing one of the comments there is
no democracy it's only two parties in the
uk labor or conservative anything else is
a wasted vote this guy has no clue actually
that guy has no clue because what he doesn't
understand is that um for example with the
liberal democrats they actually had a role
in government because you have to have a like
i don't know what the percentage of the vote is
um though so they ended up uh becoming
part of government because that's 51 you
have to have 15 if you can't then is it 51 i
thought it was more than that but they ended
but they ended up being able to bring liberal
democrat policies into government because they
needed that coalition so unfortunately that guy
doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's talking about
yeah so yeah you do need you need 51 which is what
happened in 2010 we um we had the hung parliament
and so they were supposed to do they weren't
supposed i think it was the conservatives i can't
remember so long ago well it was the conservatives
yeah but what if the problem with it was is they
had a weak person in charge of liberal democrats
who ended up giving up all of that miliband no
no ed miliband's labour um oh i can see his face
but i remember his name that's how irrelevant and
weak he is i'm too old i'm terrible with names
but they ended up kind of relenting on anything
which the liberal democrats stood for just to
get that part in government which was a real
shame but to say it's just a two-party system
is is um just wrong yeah so yeah it's it's uh
i get why people say it's a two-party system but
obviously they they did have an effect especially
when it came to rising um increasing student um
student loans or just the the cost of the cost
of university that was it because they said the
lib dem said they wouldn't increase it but then
they had to increase it because of the because
of the coalition so yeah it's true there you go
um i want to talk a little bit about canada
and what's going on with bitcoin um it was so
fascinating i think my favorite day in bitcoin has
to be the nunchuck response for the non-custodial
wallet that was just unbelievable um so empowering
so talk to me about you know your thoughts on
where bitcoin comes into all of this and how
the government are going after crypto right now
yeah i mean look super interesting i
think uh some of these people within
uh the canadian government got a lesson in what uh
censorship resistance is and self-sovereignty is
uh so that was great uh i think what happened with
gofundme and sengo whatever it's called uh i think
was a [ __ ] disgrace i mean this was legitimate
funding of a uh of a demonstration now look we can
get into specifics because some people say it was
an occupation and uh preston berm put out a very
good tweet threat that explained that look if if
if you wanted to stop the uh blockade that could
be done with under the laws that currently existed
and i think there are some good arguments to say
that um you know for the people of ottawa
because i got a lot of emails from them
that parts of the blockade were actually
damaging their business somebody wrote to me
and said they couldn't get their kids to school
another person wrote to me said their mother's
operation had been put back because she couldn't
get a hospital they are genuine issues whereby
look i support protests and sometimes you need
civil disobedience but also sometimes you say well
hold on a second if this impacts other people's
lives too negatively we need a bit of a compromise
in there but to actually um to actually take away
the funding of these people to be able to afford
to protest it's a disgrace uh but this is where
bitcoin comes in we had this with um belarus where
the lukachenko is obviously a dictator currently
supporting um uh putin's latest adventures um he
uh he stole you know he he's a dictator of belarus
and and the bela peru's belarusians try to uprise
and one of the ways they did that is they wanted
to bring the state down by having state workers
um uh strike but obviously these people need to
be able to pay their bills and feed their family
so we were able as bitcoiners to send bitcoin
to these people in belarus and support them it's
exactly the same scenario it's exactly the same
scenario these are people who want to be able to
protest they want to be able to raise their issues
of being mandated to have vaccines which i fully
support them on they should not be mandated to
have vaccines and yeah i think it was great i mean
you know the the canadian government essentially
banned these uh fundraising platforms
uh and i think it was under terrorism laws which
was ridiculous but uh and so us was bitcoin i
said great hong kong coddle let's uh donate them
bitcoin i sent some bitcoin i know a lot of other
people and we raised a lot of bitcoin for them
and it it was amazing to to to show them that
that this is the power of censorship resistance
but there is a flip side to this that we have to
be conscious of you know not only are we teaching
them about censorship resistance and self-custody
we're also then advertising this is a
threat to them so do not we should not be
surprised if this leads to maybe other forms of
regulation or attempts to get control over this
that is something we have to be aware of the the
the benefits of censorship resistance are also
a threat to the power so that is something we
need to be conscious of now i think we're more
protected in america at the moment because we
have a political opposition that really heavily
support bitcoin uh there is there is also
some in in canada but it's not as widespread
ah nick clay nick yeah i saw that as well
um i think just one thing i want to say
just about the about the truckers um and the
inconvenience that it co that it caused my
only issue with the argument about you know
people wanting to get their kids to school
and of course it's awful you know if people
can't go to operations and things like that
the problem with that is just of course it was an
inconvenience but what about what the government
did to other people it's an inconvenience you know
so how to how do you protest like how do you have
civil disobedience how do you do that because you
need to do that right because your livelihood is
literally being confiscated from you so the only
way to do that well protesting is protesting is
a spectrum um but for it to be effective right it
has to be on that far spectrum otherwise nobody's
gonna listen well look what happened during the
iraq war again i don't know how old you were at
that time but they were the biggest protests in
uk in history over a million people marching on
the street everybody knew this was going to
be a criminal war it was based on lies it was
so unpopular to the point i think we had two
politicians stepped down claire short and another
person i come for his name um that's a problem we
get an old lady forget people's names um but uh
you know they were they were largely ineffective
the largest protest in uk history and we could not
stop our government entering into an illegal
war that led to the death of one a half million
people and destabilized the entire middle east so
sometimes you have to have civil disobedience now
the the history of of the humanity
is littered with examples where
civil civil disobedience has been required to
change over policies uh or policies of oppression
so yes but like i say there has to be that this
is like a complicated area um where i think it's
important to see both and especially if you're
like hosting a podcast or you're a journalist i
think i think it's really important to try and
seek out both sides of this argument which is
you know after i did the interview with the uh
greg farson the guy supporting the campaign the
the canadian trackers i also then put out a tweet
saying look i want to hear from the other side
because i want to understand who it's affected
and why so i just i just think that's more about
responsible reporting i support protests i support
civil disobedience where it's required but i also
understand that that perhaps there's sometimes
need to be compromised it's like if this is you
know if somebody can't get to an operation how
do we fix it how do we resolve that situation
yeah no i understand um so i think that the
the establishment the canadian government
and so on didn't realize the extent
of how censorship resistant bitcoin is right
like that was just obvious from the email so
what happens at this point because the government
is angry um i'm always very much on the side of
bitcoin can't be banned there's always going
to you know the net like even whether there's
just two miners on the network in el salvador
the network is still going bitcoin still exists
it can't be banned um but what does it look like
for um innovation and our community and also just
the price as well um if more of the establishment
and world leaders wake up to just how censorship
resistant is well bitcoin can be banned it just
can't be stopped i think i think that's the point
you're trying to make yeah okay yeah you can ban
it i mean bitcoin is banned in china it hasn't
stopped everyone usually stops it correct yeah
um but i think there's two things government
governments can do they can ban it i mean it
has been banned in china it's banned in bolivia
i think it's banned in pakistan um but they
can they can regulate it to the point of being
completely useless um so we've seen various kind
of like recommendations for uh kyc extensions and
as such within the us that would essentially bring
bitcoin into just being a commodity where the
censorship resistance side is less prominent
it becomes more about the 21 million which is
you know a bit of a bit of a shame um but uh
outright ban it i don't think something that
would happen in america but you know people
can regulate exchanges they can regulate
money transmitters they could just make it very
very difficult this is why we need uh education
and we need strong people within politics which
support bitcoin which is yeah some people say i'll
ignore politics and all politicians actually no i
think there's been some great work done in america
working with politicians especially in texas
governor abbott i went to a session with him
ted cruz is a supporter of bitcoin i think um uh
josh mandel senator allam is like we've got this
growing list of people who understand bitcoin and
i think once people are educated around it once
and if you pick the right politicians politicians
who gen genuinely care about the electorate and
genuinely care about the people which do exist if
you can find those people and educate them about
the benefits of bitcoin um then you can avoid that
kind of situation what you've got to do is you've
got to also work on the morons people like senator
warren who continue to disseminate misinformation
she needs to be educated on why uh bitcoin would
be good for um progressives okay just on that
point does senator warren like she put bitcoin and
doj in the same sentence like i like doge right i
think it's really funny and but that's it that's
the extent of my interest in doge um you know
it's obviously not bitcoin but she put bitcoin and
dojo in the same sentence the other day didn't she
say that um elon musk didn't pay any tax so is
she just is she dumb or is this done on purpose
i mean how do i know how do i know what she's
up to i i i used to have faith in her i saw her
senate testimony well i mean look when mnuchin was
recommended uh under trump i saw her send a senate
questioning of him i can't remember what they
call i'm not an american but the the they have to
go through a process where they're proposed and
questioned and i saw her really go after him i
i saw her uh senate testimony here referring to uh
the removal of or the muting of glass-steagall um
which was a a a policy which essentially a policy
change which essentially led to the 2008 financial
crisis i saw her complaining that goldman sachs is
essentially uh essentially has a office within uh
the the white house like she seemed to be going
after financial corruption and the uh the bankers
and i was like okay this is somebody who would
understand bitcoin but actually really she's
just a mouthpiece just she's just a mouthpiece and
now she's going against bitcoin and so this isn't
somebody cares about the people this is somebody
who just cares about uh politicking i've got no
idea who's speaking in her ear i expect she's not
gone down the rabbit hole i don't think she's read
the bitcoin standard i don't think she's listened
to what bitcoin did i don't think she's jumped
on crypto twitter i think she's got advisors all
these politicians they have advisors who work with
them on policy and somebody's in her ear saying
this bitcoin is bad it's about the environment
let's attack it perhaps they're seeing that
there's republicans who are supporting bitcoin
they think they should go against it because
they want to make everything a political football
i've got no idea but she's a liar and she's
spreading misinformation actually she's spreading
disinformation also every time she tweets about
inflation you're like are you [ __ ] are you are
you serious like are you lying on purpose um
so yeah i just have no faith in that woman um
yeah no i agree with you you mentioned you know
people who are looking out for the electorate
people who actually care and i do agree with you i
always say you know um when a political candidate
comes out and is supposedly pro bitcoin please
have a look at their previous voting history so
we can see whether they're using this as a ploy to
get more votes because i think that's what that's
what we're going to start to see um so in the uk
you know we mentioned we spoke about matt hancock
earlier um so for those that don't know matt
hancock was the health secretary during lockdown
he was responsible for all of it he was then
cheating on his wife and banging his assistant i
think during lockdown where they told us we're not
allowed to kiss anyone or have sex with anybody
outside of your household that's what they said
and you know clearly he did quite the opposite
but um oh somebody is calling me from america let
me just decline this how weird it's coming up on
my computer um so yeah that's what they said and
i think that so he then disappeared but the first
time i saw him again he was talking about making
the uk this crypto friendly place now i'm like and
then i saw a lot of people celebrating this and
i don't believe it for a second i'm just like you
know you're using this as another way to get back
into the public light you know be liked again and
so on and so on and try to be more um seem fresh
or whatever it is so do you believe this guy do
you think you know he's got any good intentions
of making crypto and making the uk crypto friendly
does it matter well it does because he i believe
was also talking about cbdc's which we can get
into exactly obviously what we all do and and
uh magee's uh interviewed rogan this weekend
like is really highlights
the issues with that but um
i think it doesn't matter i think it's part of
the whole game theory and everything's good if
you speak to harry selleck he's got this like line
where he says everything's good for bitcoin um
if you if you if you look now someone like 30
of americans own crypto or bitcoin if you get
to the point where 50 people 50 of people own
bitcoin you have an anti-bitcoin policy you you
have a policy which attacks the wealth of the
electorate so i don't i think we get to a point
where you can't have that policy and i hope we get
into the uk yeah do i do i do i believe and trust
government as a whole no are there individuals
who i believe are good or have good in them yeah
uh i believe people get corrupted by the system
or worn down but i mean eureka rose i interviewed
her i mean she's fantastic she clearly wants to be
a politician because she wants to do good if she
if she does become a politician if
she does get a seat in the congress
maybe in 20 years she's just like any other
politician but it doesn't matter really because
if we want to grow bitcoin if we
believe this that is the ultimate good
then if these people support bitcoin fine i'll
help them i'll go see matt hancock i'll advise
him i'll tell him what he should do with his uh
bitcoin policy i've got absolutely no issue with
that whether it's genuine or not i don't care
i just want them to support bitcoin because
i believe in bitcoin i think it's good and i
also want to talk about el salvador because el
salvador has received so much hostility um from
the bank of england which is really laughable
from the us from the imf um why do you think
they've received so much hostility i mean look
i think the early days of the buccalee uh
presidency uh their actions he took which were uh
which pointed towards author authoritarian in
nature can you give me some examples well so it's
i mean they're they're a single term presidency
the constitution says so and they've changed that
policy now he'll he'll be running for another uh
another term now listen when i interviewed him
i said to him i get it i don't think one term
is long enough to do this but that is that is
a single person changing the the policy of a
country without um without going to consultation
similar to the bitcoin law as much as i support
the bitcoin law it was rushed through parliament
now this is somebody who's who's whether he's
a dictator or uh or whatever he is somebody
who's making quick and fast decisions
without really going through consultation
that said it seems to be working you know you
know i i think luckily we have something like
alex gladstein who's like the conscious conscience
of bitcoiners you know he is here's the conscience
he's the guy keeping an eye on things he's
the guy who's like observing and saying
look like we need to be careful here um i think
the problem that people have with el salvador
or buchelli specifically is he doesn't give
a [ __ ] about international institutions
he just doesn't care he doesn't care about
the imf he doesn't care about the world bank
you know these people haven't really cared
for el salvador before he recognizes that
so he's doing completely different policies
and these are policies that scare people
these are policies and i don't think it's just
about power i think it's like these people don't
actually understand bitcoin and so they see what
he's doing they think it maybe it's irresponsible
but it doesn't matter he's doing it anyway so i
don't know man i can't give you a solid answer
how does this play out though because we're yet
to see right now it's an experiment right we
refer to it as like the el salvador bitcoin
experiment um and i'm just trying to figure
out how this plays out because it kind of plays
into everything that we've been talking about
right now i think we're really at this push
and pull between um the state and the people
and we've seen that over the last two years it's
clearly increasing canada and all this stuff
are people going to be moving there i mean
we saw today like tourism is up 30 since
the bitcoin law i don't know if that's because
of covid and things like that i'm just trying
to figure out you know how far they can go with
this will other latin american countries follow
you know where's this going listen we're
meant to not trust verify uh so what i
would say is take everything with a pinch
of salt uh i saw the double digit gdp growth
i've got no idea you know my first question is
like well was there a gdp drop because of covid
and therefore is that the bounce back because
i know we had massive we had a massive gdp
increase in the uk but we had that was a bounce
back after covid you know so like i do have
questions yeah it's similar what was tourism
like during covert it obviously dropped so
so i think i think like when i saw those numbers
and people go oh my god look at this the greatest
um uh gdp growth in the el salvador history has
never been double digits i was like well hold
on a second like just give me the data and
also at the same time like he's a politician
so one of his jobs is marketing now i've got
no idea i you know we're meant to not trust
verify so uh i don't know the data it is a huge
experiment who knows how this will play out but
what i would say is i have 95 of my wealth in
bitcoin for a reason because i believe in it okay
so do i think bitcoin policy will be
good for el salvador in the long run
yes he's taken a massive brave gamble being
the first being the first is risky being the
second's left being number two three fours
less risky you don't want to be country 150
i agree with you i think you i think the usa is
going to be country 150 i've no way i mean i think
they already probably own a lot of bitcoin they've
got bitcoin they've confiscated they've got
bitcoin they'll probably keep i'm i i i absolutely
don't think they'll be the final i think europe is
going to be like one of the la like the countries
of europe are going to be one of the last
yeah it's going to be interesting to see how it
plays out so we said we chat for about an hour
and we have like 10-15 minutes left and there
is something that i feel like we should get into
um so the other day we had a bit of a
tiff and then we said in private we don't
argue um you made it a tiff i didn't
make it a tif you asked me how old i was
you retweeted it it was funny because i was
just having fun no i'm just having fun so
and i thank you the i sent you the
compromise i said let's not argue
you did and i appreciated that um so we kind of
agree or disagree a little bit on feminism and
um you know we wanted to get into this and i it's
not suitable you know your podcast is very bitcoin
only i'll talk about anything i hate feminism
and you know you were sort of asking me you know
what do i do if i have you know daughters and
i want to tell them that they can do anything
so what is feminism feminism i think
initially at the start feminism i would
i would believe in right in terms of equality
you know women should have the right to vote
and looking at like the actual legalities in this
world and sort of saying you know do we have equal
laws like are we treated equally and for me
that's sort of where it starts and ends right
now feminism is is i think more detrimental to
women unfortunately um i think it's gone too far
well what part what part has gone too far
the biggest issue and i'll tell you this
is some as a woman in her 20s who's who's had a
change of heart about a lot of different things
feminism lies to you okay feminism tells
you yeah feminism tells you be a boss [ __ ]
right when you're 18 and 19 yeah sure be a boss [
__ ] as you get older there is no there's no woman
i'd show me a woman who's 40 the ceo of a company
super successful no children tell me she's happy
because she's not that's basically what the path
that feminism likes to take you down so feminism
is about telling women to to go and be a boss [ __
] and then they might miss out on having a child
because i think feminism is like the scope of
feminism is way wider than that and i think
about feminism from the point of being a single
father with a daughter who asks me questions
yeah she comes home from school she said oh the
boys got to do this why don't we get to do it
what did they get to do like it might be the boys
play football we don't get to play football we
play netball i'm like do you want to play
football she's like i don't know but like
maybe or the boys are a bit you know tend to
take over and dominate things like yeah she just
comes back with questions and i always have to
empower and say you can do everything that a boy
does or you can do everything you know so
like i i'm trying to as a father and power
to think she is equal and this it takes me back
to this kind of world of libertarianism one of
the oh let's go to and caps one of the reasons
i have issues with anarcho-capitalism is that
negative liberty really uh is something i've been
reading about which is something this kind of
guy isaiah berlin wrote about but the issue
with negative liberties empowers the strong
and um it disempowers the weak and one of
the great things i saw this great interview
with jordan peterson where this guy talks
about like the civil rights moves civil
well no he was actually a guy making that was
challenging uh jordan peterson with regards to
uh should should a cake shop be able to uh refuse
to make a cake for a gay couple and he's yeah
and he said no and and uh and then he brought
him up on the idea of the civil rights movement
and and jordan peterson you know did 180
said actually i had that issue wrong and
this is one of the things that like i love about
centralization and statism is that that we have
had these progressions in society that have made a
more equal society that we've we've uh we have had
the civil rights movement we have uh uh created
more equal opportunity for women in the workplace
and so me as a father like a lot of that has come
from women themselves as well of course it has so
yes everything is everything always has a spectrum
i'm sure of feminism there's a bunch of absolute
freaks out there who just like just promote
really weird [ __ ] but at the same time like
my if my daughter wants to have a
career and she wants to go out and
be successful i'm absolutely gonna support
her i'm not gonna turn around and say no
darling you need to be prepared at 24 to start
thinking about marriage and babies because you
might miss out on that later in life i can't
tell my daughter that there's no way i can tell
her that and you're like that might lead to her
getting into her 40s and not having a child and
you know being sad about that but there's also for
every woman you say who's sad about that there are
also women who are sad they missed out on building
a career and only raise children there's always
that thing where the grass is always greener it's
about it's about being honest it's about having an
honest conversation so i would say i'm somewhat
successful for my age and what i do and i would
put much of that success down to my brother
so my brother has always empowered me right
i think and this is the thing with men and women
with feminism actually i think feminism sort of
disregards the value of men i think there's
so much that that i can learn from a man
to be successful in life in many different ways
not just work like i i value men so much like i
look up to men i think men are amazing not all men
most men i think i think are pretty great right
so i would attribute a lot of my success to my
brother because he's hugely empowered me and said
to me you can do anything your gender has nothing
to do with it but what i think is important is to
have an honest conversation with your daughters
and say you know have that career because i think
actually women should be financially independent
that's really important every individual should
be financially independent so you're not um
you know relying on either the government or
your partner but have an honest conversation and
just say you know like you will turn an age and
you don't have as much time as a man and these
things are a matter of fact and it's about not
not not not addressing that
because that's what we tend to see
like i tell you i i said to this what i think that
i think there's a way bigger problem with dating
apps than feminism for women i do i fundament i've
got a theory on this and uh so when i was like
when i was uh your age lei if you wanted to get a
girlfriend you you'd have to talk to somebody in
real life human form you'd be in a bar or you'd
be in a club and if you saw a girl you're like
god she's hot like and i need to go and talk
to her and it was a terrifying experience and
it made you a man and it no if you got no no like
everyone every guy is a [ __ ] when it comes to
this your partner you've always got this like one
friend of us but like you would go and do it right
and occasionally you get rejected and it's like
it's heartbreaking it's killer but like every now
and again a girl would be like yeah hey talk
to you back and then maybe like you would ask
her out and she'll say yes just like holy [ __
] i've got a date and then maybe like after the
date she would want to see you again and like if
you were like super lucky she would actually want
to have sex sex with you and it was like it was
like this experience that you would go through
and and maybe you'd be like wow this person is
amazing and you would stick with it and it was
a real challenge for guys and women controlled it
and the problem you've got now with dating apps
it's like guys don't really have to [ __ ] work
anymore that they've they've swapped out going up
and talking to somebody and having a pair of
balls to do that with a swipe ah she says no
great go to the next one all right i've got 50 new
matches today hey do you want to go out join the
[ __ ] like they've just made it so easy for guys
and it's flipped the script when i speak to my
my friends who are girls they're like it's an
absolute nightmare no guy wants to commit now
we've created this kind of like
culture of [ __ ] boys yeah there's
this culture of [ __ ] boys which is absolutely
terrible and it's flipped the script and i think
that's a bigger problem for women in that all
these girls i know in their 30s it's not that
they can't have a baby they can't find someone
to have a baby because no guy wants to commit
it's such an interesting topic um it's also
there's so much to this that i just shouldn't say
on a podcast um someone just as you're speaking
i'm just thinking no i mean what were these women
doing in their 30s you know i don't know how
they behave you know you if you want to if you
want to attract somebody of high value to have
a baby with you have to be high value yourself
and you have to compromise and you have to do
certain things so i don't know these women in
their 30s they might be saying you know that
everyone's a [ __ ] boy but what were you how
are you behaving when you were 23 24 25 i don't
know how they were behaving so there's another
there's another you know part to that i
think there are really good men out there
i think there are really good women out there
um but if you want to attract high value
then you have to be high value and that does mean
compromising you know as a man that might mean
working incredibly hard that might mean you know
physically looking gorgeous you know getting your
body in shape it might mean working incredibly
hard to make a lot of money as a woman it might be
sacrificing certain things you know having to do
certain things for your husband whether that's
like you know cooking cleaning i don't
know whatever it is but you know these
these sort of things require compromise so i
don't know what they were doing i know that
a lot of women in their 20s unfortunately um
behave really badly so i'm not surprised when
a lot of women are just women men and women behave
badly it's like a human nature and on the whole i
suspect it's men who tend to behave more badly
because we're [ __ ] idiots and we don't mean
that kind of behave badly i don't mean that kind
of behavior what do you mean i mean like oh man
we could we gotta i've gotta run you gotta run
we we could talk about this for ages are you
gonna run i i i have a networking event tonight at
seven in an hour i've gotta okay let me just say
what i mean by this what i mean by this is
men don't like women that have been with the
entire community right you just don't men
just don't like that you're avoiding this
well listen firstly there's no way a guy has to
find that out that's secret information and and
i don't know many women like that and look if a
girl wants to go and be [ __ ] but that's up to
her i mean look of course it's up to her but i'm
just saying like this is going to be detrimental
in terms of finding the kind of person that you
want to find and so you get to 30 and you're
wondering why you're still single why why did why
does it mean that's like what you know who knows
what's happened maybe they've gone to university
then they've got a job now they get into their
like late 20s they want to settle down and they
just find it difficult i think i think there's
a myriad of reasons i think it's difficult to
binary place on one thing i think also just like
the world has changed like relationships have
become like uber like oh i want a relationship
tonight i don't want one tomorrow yeah instant
gratification i think a lot of that's happening um
um i think that i think there's like a whole bunch
of reasons uh i know you want to go all right
no no but like no no you need to go and we can
do this again we could do this a hundred times
look i'm i'm massively out of my depth here i
don't know what the [ __ ] i'm doing i've got a 12
year old a 12 year old girl who like comes to me
and asks me stuff and there is no way i can turn
around her and say darling listen you need to be
preparing for when you're about 24 25 think about
having a baby because it's gonna be harder in your
30s and so you need to find yourself a man and
you know who can look after you i just i
can't do that i can't have that conversation
maybe her mom can maybe that can come from her mum
but i'm not gonna like perpetuate this belief in
her her eyes that like it's a man's world because
it still exists but it's not a man's word i'm not
saying it's a man's world because it's such a such
a kind of worms it's not a it's not a man's world
um i have right now i would actually argue that
it's it's both it's both but you know there's
a lot of advantage to being a woman in this
world right now um but as a 12 year old girl
i don't think there's many guar like boys coming
home from school and saying to their their dad
go ahead oh the girls get to do this i wish we
did i don't i don't think that happens as much
but it definitely happens with a 12 year old girl
so there still is that thing and you know and i i
just i don't have it in my heart to turn around
her and say sorry darling but like you need to
be like like say maybe it's this conversation for
our mum to have and that that's fair but i don't i
don't have that in me i just i can't do that no
i respect that but what i will what i will say
you've got this guy matthew that matthew mccauley
following the conversation like he's just let me
see he just is correct wait where is it oh it's
gone women's fertility is fine talk you know what
peter we need to do an impersonal podcast okay no
i'm just going to reply to him like of course i
can explain biological reality mate i can explain
biological reality but at the same time i'm
balancing the hopes and dreams of a young girl i'm
not going to try and crush it by telling her at 12
years old she needs to think about having a baby
you [ __ ] idiot i'm just reading your comments
what i'll say is this is this is my this is
like where my feminism starts and ends it's that
every individual including women should never rely
on somebody else whether it's the government or
their partner their husband their wife for
financial security that's very dangerous
so every individual should be empowered and
should have their own financial stability that
way how do you ban how do you balance building
financial security but having this fertility
ticking time bomb it's [ __ ] [ __ ] how do you
balance that i don't know i'm in the middle of
doing it i'm balancing it it's really [ __ ] but
but that's life that's life and it's a reality and
it's a reality that i accept it's a reality that i
accept and so i work harder than men i work harder
to do to so that i can have everything by 30.
this is what jordan peterson talks about this
is just the reality of it but the important thing
is that i'm that i'm far away from 30 and so i'm
very aware at this stage and that is important
it's just awareness it's awareness of reality
which not a lot of women have so when they get
to 30 30 1 30 22 30 35 still single and they're
unhappy and they don't understand why they can't
find someone and it's it's a whole can of worms um
but it's about having an honest conversation and
that's why it is harder that's why women grow up
faster than men do women get periods at 12 years
old and have to deal with that in public like
how do you deal with that you go swimming you
know and boys can still be children at that age
so women have it's harder to be a woman in
certain regards but it is what it is it's okay and
you know there are many advantages at the same
time men it's also very hard to be a man at
the same time you know because there are a lot of
really difficulties i've not found it hard at all
no not quite hard no i don't find it and i think
when i hear people complain and go it's so hard
for a like like a white male they said i just
don't experience that i i personally haven't uh i
think every opportunity is in front of me there's
no blocks in front of me for what i want to do but
i do see there's blocks for other people you know
depending on you know the luck of the draw there
are gender blocks there are uh ethnic like uh
ethnicity blocks there are geographical blocks i i
just don't have any in front of me but like i say
i have a daughter and i'm trying to be empathetic
to her trying to lead her in in the right way
and explain certain things in the right way and
some of it you don't want to get it wrong some
of it's quite challenging and uh it's very easy
for somebody to comment to just jump in there and
just like come out with a comment like they know
suddenly what the answer is these are complicated
issues you know these are complicated things
you're dealing with when you're parenting and
you want to give your child the best opportunity
you want to empower them you don't want to scare
them uh but but you like right now i'm like holy
[ __ ] so i need to think about this as well and
this is another thing so i'm gonna have to talk to
my mother and go on the phone and say at what
point do we deal with this you know it's like
you should it's just about being too complicated
yeah yeah it's just about being truthful and you
know she can do anything she wants she can be
that boss ceo like i i love what i do it comes
from my heart it's not really it's not about money
it's about freedom and i'm not going to stop but
unfortunately you know i do want to be a mother as
well and so not unfortunately but like it's just
unfortunate that i have these two things that i
want um and so i will have to figure out a way to
do both and i'm just grateful that i'm aware at
this age because i'd be very upset if i woke up
you know i wish i was aware even younger that you
know that's the truth i wish i was aware younger
but listen listen it's you know it's great that
you have that not everyone not every girl does
not everyone would have the confidence to start a
podcast and go on and you know you know what it's
like i mean you take [ __ ] online and get all the
negative comments on you you choke i'm all weirdos
and everyone complaining and you get the backseat
listeners who think they can do a better job and
really just because their lives are miserable and
their complete failures they can't do anything
but they want to sit there and have a go at you
you've got the confidence to go out and do that
you're you're in the arena you take the beatings
and do it now i know what it's like and it's tough
not everyone has that like not everyone has
that ability to do that and you will be hugely
successful you're going to make a lot of money
doing really well i mean you're crushing it at
24. is it 24 i don't know i'm guessing i'm not 24.
if you're younger i'm going to be depressed but
i'm saying you are absolutely crushing it right
but not everybody has that confidence that ability
they don't have maybe the educational background
they don't have the maybe you've got supporting
parents and they're impacted yeah so or maybe
you didn't have supporting parents and it like
spurred you on like there's like the world is made
up of different people and and not everyone can go
and do that i'm glad for you that you can but not
everyone's going to go out and be able to do that
be able to get financially secure and independent
not rely on a man and and and and but still you
know put themselves in a position when they want
to go and have a baby and and be able to support
themselves it doesn't work like it's it's highly
complex right yes [ __ ] hard all right i have to
run into london now i'm going to get an uber i'm
too far away um but i've had so much fun chatting
with you i'm so happy we did this and we'll have
to do it again in person whether it's in london
or miami i don't know where we'll do it but peter
i want to thank you so much um i'll do it anytime
you enjoy this i always talk to you and uh but
let's do it let's do it in person next time and
yeah comments come turn the comments off because
honestly that [ __ ] idiots fed up a little bit
no but thank you so much it's been so good with
you and let me know when you're in miami or if
you're in london and we'll we'll meet up and we'll
do another one in person all right cool anything
you need just give me a shout yeah perfect take
care and i'm gonna see i'm seeing you in miami
yeah yes i'll be there in april hopefully they'll
let me in um but yeah i'm about to put my flights
this week so yeah all right cool i will see
that my daughter will be there you can meet her
oh that'll be great i'll i'll empower her
to go get her dreams while looking for her
no i'm joking she's too young okay
all right take care peace out bye